so then how did you transition from
doing all the online stuff into then
actually like
living here permanently because i assume
you had to figure out a way right yeah i
mean this is one of the biggest
questions
you know everyone wants to like how do
you live in japan because you get it all
the time as well yeah
i mean i mean let's uh
it's it's a difficult thing because
there's so many people i'm sure you've
had the same experience like people who
are living here it's like
how are you living here like you don't
you think like do you you have to do
something
what visa do you have how how have you
coined how how have you game the system
in your own way right it's a
it's sort of like uh uh you're not
supposed to ask that question like
how what visa and how are you here like
because well look some people just
um you know they're lucky like oh my
my father is japanese i've got a visa
yeah yeah or like um i'm
not lucky you know i mean like i'm not
saying it's a bad thing yeah or like
you know some for some reason they're
here uh
so the way i did it was um so originally
working holiday visa
and then when that started to run out
was i thought okay i need to do
something
and i had a friend who lived up in um
uh sendai who was a french guy
and he was actually running a mag as a
french magazine he was running the
magazine as the editor from japan
oh okay so he was just getting all this
content from japan just
editing it yeah and it was so he was on
a journalist visa
oh okay so i thought he said you should
do the journalist visa it's very easy
so sorry jc that's a bad
um so i i thought okay maybe i can do
this so i applied for everything
now remember when the earthquake oh you
went here when the earthquake happened
the earthquake
yeah the earthquake happened right and
and i'd already sort of renewed once and
it worked and i thought okay i don't
know if i can do this again
uh it was kind of easy the first time
because i
i managed to get like a contract from a
magazine right
and i don't know if it would work these
days or not but
you know i had proof that i'd been doing
that job for a long time and the best
thing about being a journalist
is you don't need any sort of uh
qualification yeah you don't
all you need is like i've done this for
a long time
yeah i'm gonna keep doing it these guys
are gonna pay me to do it okay so i
sort of convinced them a magazine to
give me a contract like look you want
this content
give me a contract yeah right okay so i
got that i showed them
uh then again that whole earthquake
thing happened
um and this was like literate the same
time i was meant to renew
i thought oh no what if they cancel me
or
right so i mean look everyone i don't
know about you guys it's like a panic
state
it's all it's all what was that like
okay
when i it was it was wasn't bad for me
because all i did was just sort of sit
at home for like a month and just do
nothing i just thought i'm just going to
stay the hell out of it yeah
until i need to do something actually my
um i did go and help a friend who
was at ebisu uh who had a lot of trouble
with stuff falling down the hill like it
collapsed
anyway yeah right right right so i
thought okay
i i i don't want to leave if i leave now
probably not going to come back yeah
right because a lot of you know the
whole fl you haven't heard fly jin you
heard that term
like no yeah so foreigners who left
japan when the earthquake happened was
like i'm out
is that a real thing like yeah well okay
it was a it was kind of a derogatory
thing it's like yeah you left it's like
i
honestly don't blame people who did that
because it was that bad understandable
have a nice
footage of it but it's so hard to like
actually get a sense of it because even
the small earthquakes here kind of like
throw me off sometimes yeah i can only
imagine what an earthquake of that
magnitude
i do i don't know if i don't i don't
think people can quote me on this but
wasn't it like one of the most like
financially it was one of the most like
devastating earthquakes
slash tsunamis of like all time or
something well probably
yeah i think it like caused the most
damage like financially and yeah
caused a lot of problems really [ __ ]
up this japanese economy
depending on how severe i hear it was is
depending on
who i asked and where they were at the
time yeah because some people said like
i've been told this like it wasn't that
bad things just started falling yeah no
it was bad yeah but like so i'm saying
right depends on who you ask and where
they were at the time right because
obviously if someone experienced it and
it wasn't bad for them they probably
think like huh
i mean it was on like everything
like it was you know it was [ __ ]
worldwide
no i i know i'm not saying it's not what
i'm asking is like how was it for like
you because everyone i seem to ask so
far has such a different explanation for
me
for them personally i mean when it
actually happened i was uh so i was
about i was just doing some washing at
the time it was like
because it's like in the afternoon i
thought uh i'm gonna take it down to the
laundromat and get the dryer going
and something cause i was gonna hang up
as well and
the windows started rattling i'm like oh
it's windy good i can get my mic
if i can watch this hang my sheets out
get them to dry
and then all of a sudden everything
started i was on the second floor of a
of a house that i used to live in
and it started to move i'm like oh
earthquake okay
um what do i do okay stand in the so i
stood in the door in the door frame
right
he's supposed to do it yes i think
that's what you're supposed to do and it
started to
it's just doing this and i'm like oh
okay this is bad wait i'm i'm supposed
to be a media guy where's my camera
so i grabbed my bloggy again yeah and i
caught the last like 20 seconds
on video right like i aimed out the
window all the lines are
the power lines are doing this and it's
rattling and it's just crazy
and i remember it like that too and then
it's just kind of stopped and
there was a guy doing a delivery like a
i couldn't echo guy over the road he
just kept doing the stamp and he
going like nothing happened yeah it's
gonna happen
and i'm looking at there's no smoke
rising it's okay it should be okay
and so i put my stuff in my laundry
anything went down to the laundromat and
i'm in there
just sitting there waiting for it to dry
i was like i'll go shopping maybe in a
minute
and these kids walk past the window
outside wearing those
uh those those hats you know they're the
foam yeah
yeah it's like it's it's like this like
kind of uh it's like a trailer it's like
a bandana looking thing that they wear
and it's supposed to be fireproof
yeah yeah kids like elementary school
kids wear it uh to like kind of protect
themselves it's like a red riding hood
hood but it's like a thick foam with
like made of reflectives like an old
fireman's hat sort of thing oh my god
yeah in the uk
they'll like [ __ ] get on with it i
mean there's nothing that happens in the
uk that's big enough to be worried about
right
they'll walk past the window i'm like
what the hell are these oh oh they're
wearing those things okay
and then in the laundry room there's tv
sometimes there's a tv yeah
and i look up and there's that the big
black wall of death just eating towers
yeah
yeah wow
oh [ __ ] i better go get some i better go
and buy some food or something
so i i just i went to the supermarket
and just bought a bunch of food and i
thought
i can and a slab
so it was okay for me like the worst
thing for doing car content was there
was no fuel
they just cut all the fuel got cut off
so i was like okay and what i actually
did that month was i had enough of an
internet presence then to say
that i had a regular column in a
japanese magazine actually and i said
hey everyone send me a picture of your
foreign drift car and i got people to do
to make my content for me yeah
but you're a pro youtuber yeah yeah yeah
yeah goddamn
but up in uh in in tohoku like up where
especially where my ebisu is absolutely
yeah i had to go up there to help a
friend
just so you weren't in sendai when it
actually happened
no no no i wasn't up there because
because my grandma lives in sendai sorry
she like uh yeah because what i've heard
is that from people who were in sendai
near the epicenter it was
awful but then i've heard a lot of
people in tokyo who are like yeah things
were shaking yeah well i mean
for my grandma i was kind of like half
off because like she
lives on like a quite a big like
apartment place right yeah i think she
was on like the 13th or 14th floor or
something
and like obviously the higher up on the
building you are right the more it's
going to shake
but like you know it didn't break
anything like she didn't get injured or
whatever
but then she did tell me that like it
was really scary that
after the rattling kind of stopped and
she picked herself back up and looked
out the window
she could actually see the tsunami
coming over the horizon oh my
god and and then she was like oh [ __ ]
and so she turned the tv on and then you
know the that really famous like footage
right
yeah wall was just uh wait what is the
black wall it's i
i just made like that's because i just
made that up yeah it's it's it's
the tsunami was just like a big churning
dark mess
it wasn't like there's like one big wave
that most people think it is it was kind
of just this
rush of water they're just coming in
because of like
because it was just taking all the
debris with it
right so it's just like oh it just turns
into a black wolf like destruction
because it wasn't like it's hardly water
anymore because it was just like all the
gunk that you would have
taken up all the houses that were along
the coast were just getting crushed
as this thing came over and it was yeah
it was horrible meanwhile international
people like were like
but my anime like pokemon got delayed or
something madoka got delayed people were
like yeah
they're like i can't believe this is
stopping the anime it's like it's like
it's like [ __ ] you i mean they think you
know trains were cancelled for a while
and they had rolling blackouts
yeah luckily because i was the grid that
i was on in my house was um the same
grid as a big hospital
and a japanese military base so we never
got a cut right here's the thing so
what i was saying before was i had to
renew my visa
and at that point you had to get a
re-entry visa to come back into the
country
all right which means you have to go to
the visa center get
like a 20 stamp in your thing your
passport so
if you leave the country you can come
back and everyone's leaving because it's
like well
there's radiation landing on yeah yeah i
mean
understandably yeah yeah so and i was
just i thought okay fine
but i was like trying to renew my thing
at the same time so i went to the visa
center
at like three in the afternoon which is
a bad idea i drove there
out in saitama right and the queue was
about 300 meters long
of people i thought it was anime expo i
had to i thought okay
here's what i have to do okay i have to
come back tomorrow morning
before the first train yeah so my car
because my car ran on premium
fuel this is a drift car right uh no no
fuel
i don't know i like it to mention yeah
just reminding you
just it was a drift car okay so i i i
begged my friend like please lend me
your little k
car your little small compact car so i
can drive out there before the first
train so i can get in line get there
there's already about
maybe 50 meters of people lined up oh my
god i didn't get in the front door until
i lined up
like maybe 4 30 in the morning didn't
get there in the front door until
two in the afternoon and then as soon as
i got in the front door
everyone's going to the left i go to the
right to renew
right and i walk up there's not at the
counter because they're all busy over
here i'm like right
um and some someone walks past like um
what do you want
oh i want to renew they're like oh okay
they just take it they sort of just
flick through like
you got you got your tax thing in there
it's like oh i i forgot that it's like i
don't worry about it
and then and then just as i went back i
was like oh that's over thank god for
that and go home
went to the car park to get my coin
parking little gates
right so get in the car go to drive out
and go to the gate put my money in the
machine all i had was a hundred
like a ten thousand yen like 100 yeah
you can put them in the machines here
put it in the machine
the gates open it's like where's my
change
four o'clock scheduled blackout oh
no so the machine ate my hundred dollar
bill i'm like oh no
yeah like i looked around like all the
all the lights are blanked out
coming out of the bank because it just
got blacked out i'm like oh no so anyway
i
i called up and this being japan there
was a very lovely girl and she's like
you know answering the phone yeah i'm
sorry the machine ate my hundred dollars
she's like oh don't worry we'll
oh okay we'll we'll make sure we'll make
sure it's okay and we'll send you the
money we'll get you information of your
bank
sure enough like a week later they did
it i mean japan's the one country where
you probably wouldn't mind a machine
eating your money yeah
you know you're getting that bank yeah
you're gonna have a bag so yeah that was
a that was a thing so since then but now
i'm married with kids and i'm an adult
now
gosh terrifying proper adult what's that
what's that like
[Music]